في الاثناء قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان
الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغ نظيره الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي ان واشنطن ستقدم عددا
محدودا من صواريخ اتا كامز ارض ارض بعيده
المدى للمساعده في الحرب مع روسيا
المسؤولون الامريكيون اوضحوا ان هناك
نقاشا بشان نوع وعدد الصواريخ التي سيتم
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا ونقلت وسائل اعلام
امريكيه عن مسؤولين ان واشنطن ستزود
الصواريخ المخصصه لاوكرانيا بقنابل
عنقوديه بدلا من راس حرب واحد وهذا سيمنح
لاوكرانيا القدره على استهداف موقع
القياده مواقع القياده ومخازن الذخيره خلف
الخطوط الاماميه
الروسيه وقبل قليل قال البيت الابيض انه
لن يؤكد التقارير بشان تزويد اوكرانيا
بانظمه صواريخ اتا كامز مشيرا الى ان
تقديم الدعم لكيف مستمر